on les appelait de la vie si tout con
quand est astucieux belle
a priori c'est le plus sérieux
[Musique]
quitte à jouer il est devenu un ami au
bayern bah oui les notes dit ouais avant
de commencer oui tu dis bonjour la page
a dit bonjour à tous nos amis tu dis
bonjour tu fait une grimace aux promos
abbassi piste après une imitation en
vitesse je fais une grille mari et je
tapais limite assure fois une grimace tu
te fasses moi je ne sais pas moi c'est
la guitare à l'onf et la guitare basse
et la chèvre vas-y c'est fabuleux fait
on s'y croirait c'est fabuleux
on joue maintenant au jus du pays bas la
géographie le contour le contour le
drapeau est là le drapeau oui et s'est
caché derrière la fleur ici la très bien
alors tu connais le principe d'abord je
le découvre le conte autour du pays
voilà ensuite le drapeau est ensuite
bonjour dans la langue du pays
exactement inverse il fait comme
insatisfaite
bien oui au chômage c'est la mer ça me
rappelle quelque chose le bleu c'est la
mer bien sûr et puis ça c'est le pays
que nous devons chercher quelqu'un de
beauté ben c'est la capitale c'est la
capitale
le drapeau le drap pour le voilà sobre
sans armement mais beau nous avons rouge
ici rouge ici et jaune au milieu très
difficile savoir maintenant voyons un
petit peu là bonjour dans la langue du
pays
buenos dias bien à buenos dias seniors
comme je vais essayer de le dire buenos
dias seniors
bravo au lait je pense que vous n'avez
pas eu beaucoup de difficulté à
reconnaître notre voisin l'espagne
voisine
enfin notre voisine si tu veux n'allez
pas un geek le
avec son drapeau et puis bon jour
l'espagnol qui se dit bois logis à la
chignole a dit aux seniors qui obéit au
verglas dans les garder nos voiles à
laon gatineau à tout à l'heure
allez tout à l'heure bon il est parti
alors dit depuis belle belle épouse
moussu oui vous êtes prêt on va faire le
point comme un bien sûr aux résultats
non mais qu'est ce que des faits mois
ouh la la qu'est ce que c'est que ça via
riz varie à hyères qui n'a pas cet
escargot de mahler avec lui on va
sûrement pas tu ne l'as pas bah non je
n'ai pas vu ce jour qui nous dans une
laitue
ah bon tu crois en toi oui jma soir
alors qu est-ce qu on est au fait qu'est
ce que tu fais là toi là qu'est ce que
tu fais là se présente je m'appelle
piquant bull et non et ben moi je
m'appelle fabry rabat s'est fabriqué bas
face vous connaît oui je vous ai déjà
regardé la maternelle et tous vos petits
camarades
oui bah écoute de bell bell est en boule
tout tu es gentil qui reste la [ __ ] nous
laisse jouer parce qu'on a des choses à
dire à aller à toutes les vérités
ailleurs leurs ailerons qui soit pas
jaloux tout cas encore aller le point
commun j'avais également alors on joue
au jeu des points communs mais du tout
bon
alors moi aujourd'hui quand tu veux te
cool et mise à l'épreuve déçu qu'est ce
que j'ai je suis très célèbre à paris
j'ai ouïe ouïe très célèbre mais ayant
déjà dit il ya des cousines et des
cousins dans d'autres villes de france
mais alors vous savez à côté de moi ils
sont tout petit tout petit ah bon oui
parce que on vient deux des quatre coins
du monde me voir à paris on me
photographie on grimpe le long de moi et
puis et puis qui si on se contente pas
de maintenir et on me filme aussi oui
voilà c'est tout ce que j'ai à dire oui
bah je vois pas du tout ce que c'est
pour l'instant aller c'est difficile
bell bell qu'est ce que tu as et toi
c'est amusant parce que moi je ne suis
pas du tout le centre de quelque chose
de paris ou d'ailleurs non je suis
exactement
traire par exemple à paris on peut me
trouvais aussi mais il ne faut pas
rentrer dans la ville il faut rester sur
le bord
attends je vais te donner un autre
exemple blake est bien pour trouver il
faut te promener sur le bord du lac
parcourez les lives de cela d'un bout à
l'autre
et quand il sera revenu à tamponner
départ alors qui pourra dire que tu me
connaissent assez calé en transit dont
je vois pas du tout cette fois ci je
suis bien embêté la pousse moussu oui
oui eh ben moi moi je suis très très
adroit
ça vous étonne je suis quelque chose
dont se servent les prestiges les
prestiges et alors là la ccc très
difficile à prononcer attendait les les
prestidigitateurs voile à bord et là je
fais apparaître ou disparaître les
objets les plus inattendus des lapins
des foulards des oiseaux tiens je
pourrais faire aussi disparaître tout
temps
ouais je sais pas si je pourrai ou bien
le le changer aux citrouilles
je pourrais sortir de ta poche un citron
un fromage ou un jeu de cartes et tu ne
saurait pas du tout comment je me suis
pris un
c'est ça le miracle de la prestine de
l'arrivée stygi c'est ça allait enfin
quand même nous le dira mais comme je
lis tout à l'heure quand j'étais très
jeune et bien voulez-vous je veux dire
une chose tous les droits
oui je crois bien que c'est la première
fois que vous m'avez coller dans le jeu
du point c'est aujourd'hui
eh ben je ne sais pas je donne ma langue
au chat pas aujourd'hui je ne sais pas
quel est le point commun que vous avez
bien à vous
tous là à tuer tout cas encore la tour
eiffel à toi bell bell c'était le tour
de paris où il est toujours là et moi et
moi et moi le tour du prestige et du
jura explique enfin pas oui c'est ça le
tour le tour ou la tour a très bien et
pas cette fois-ci vous m'avez eu c'est
un grand champion comme ça j'ai dit à
quoi je vais essayer d'avoir aussi à mon
tour vacances les plaies c'est celui là
alors mes petits amis à tout à leur
belle belle c'est à toi pour smooth
whitney à moitié à peu près où je suis
presque sûr que ça va marcher cette fois
je suis fin prêt we can oui ça c'est une
véritable catastrophe alors attention je
vais aller bon tu vas au dessus méfie
toi un oui au je me méfie bande à quoi
bon alors alors cette fois ci c'est un
mot en huile être celui-là on commence
par la première c'est un achat h oui
alors je fais citerai riz 1 2 3 4 5 6 la
dernière et la dernière un des indes et
comme denis et rêver qu'est ce que c'est
un animal
ah non non non c'est pas un animal c'est
un arbre ah oui oui un petit à petit une
planche c'est un petit arbre vieux y en
a en france d'ailleurs ghana en france
voilà en france y en a en france est un
petit à ccc rouges no je pense du pont
soit depuis deux clubs ont pas est ce
que tu veux que je te donne une petite
lettre supplémentaire je veux bien oui
alors je vais te donner la 4e les oui
s'il te plaît c'est un b 1b crie alors 1
2 3 4 1 b alors alors alors cadets cela
est ce que c est ce que ça a une utilité
oui oui c'est ce que ça se mange ça ce
sas boirai plus tôt c'est à dire ça ça
sert à fabriquer une boisson
alors là je t'aide que là je attends tu
perds mais avec un âge oui
un n 1 n
oui non non non non mais dis donc il ya
une chose qui va pas là comme un
charlatan
tu me dis que ça ses affaires une
boisson ça comme henri parent h c'est
sympa houblon houblon et ben voilà
comment houblon bas à chaud hub et l om
des pauvres fous pas comme un pauvre fou
regarde comment on écoule ont décidément
tu est incorrigible il ya jamais eu de
dea houblon et à n
à la fin à giroud mais l ol que blon ça
s'écrit vient avec un des blancs quand
tu es blonde les cheveux mais par mais
pas où l'on roule vraiment que je veux
tu peux me dire sur le bradage peut dire
qu'il ya un roi d'angleterre qui fait
son lit qui remplit son oreiller avec
les fruits du houblon lui et et ça le
faisait dormir parce que le houblon
c'est très bon pour le sommeil 1 une
salle est parent allemand et puis c'est
pas dangereux
voilà en plus c'est pas dangereux mais
dis moi tu m'as dit le blond fait que
les boissons la bière la bière gardien
bien sûr mais oui la bière je te l'avais
pas dit maintenant alors j'ai dû oublier
basse et là c'est bien mais
l'orthographe c'est toujours à bâle
orthographe l'abri c'est important
l'orthographe mais oui oui pour sa belle
belle qui est sûr je tâtonne nous
écoutons toi fabrice qu'à jouer avec moi
[Musique]
c'est facile la musique tibétains genre
je rappelle je rappelle à tous nos amis
que lui
nous allons j'en étais note que j'ai dit
que je vais les mettre les inscrire sur
une portée si les actes et menton clé de
sol et que je vais
écoutez ce que tu vas me raconter si
compléter les mots que tu auras premier
et chaque fois que je ferais ou que je
laisserai un silence boîtier mais craint
une note de musique
on y voit là non je voudrais te donner
un concert puisque tu es comme moi et
que tu ne pars pas en vacances
je voudrais te dire qu'on peut très bien
s'amuser en 1 me au bas en famille en
famille à l'être of la note ça bien sûr
là on reste chez soi on s'amuse très
bien et l'autre jour on a des dés de se
déguiser aube à dessiner des cités ci
s'est déguisé et on a passé une journée
formidable formidable voilà je me suis
déguisé en corsaire j'avais un pantalon
pas une et us est un pote à loire sûrs
ça c'est très très 21 mai qu'ils veulent
moi j'étais hors oui bah oui c'est très
bien mais rapide hausse mais laisse nous
faire ce que veut faire notre gîte pour
réguler les eaux vives à rudy riou
hinchey atarot une chat
il est bien sûr la pub était enfoncé b
oui j'ai ré tout simplement pour me
donner anja terrible je m'étais mis un
bon sur l'oeil abandon je suppose des
condos voilà applique le rouge à lèvres
j'aime et et brighi catrice quoi tu
mettais un briquet patrice fabriquer une
cicatrice ans j'en peux plus mais là
j'avais avant mais ça si c'est comme ça
je vais essayer de jouer ça un petit peu
près n'importe quoi je vais quand même
du citron difficile femmes
[Musique]
et
c'est bizarre tu terrible c'est bizarre
me fout c'est vrai ça bêle bêle oui
alors que rien avec tous j'arrive tout
de suite ces machins bien aujourd'hui
oui les quatre stars ni déjà les cas ça
ne vous diront que secrète que la vie
est belle et j'ai shop se déchausse les
comme jenny pas de mine war il faudra
faire attention les gars ça y sont
partagés sont réunis les cas ça me sens
heureux d'arisem la vie
j'aimerais voir ça mais vous avez à
jouer aujourd'hui il le vouloir je veux
ni azami insu si de vouloir devenir amis
[Musique]